what is the police force for if it is
not for investigating crime well the
police also exists primarily as the
inspector who isn't a very identifies to
prevent crime and of course if one of
the figures I understand the tweets
you're receiving but crime is falling
antisocial behavior is falling and
competence in policing is remaining
fairly stable so whilst as much to do as
much to be reassured about in the report
in the bulk of the report as well what
about the fact that it depends where you
live if you for example are in
warwickshire nearly two-thirds of crime
scenes are not attended by a police
officer well the report identifies a
wide spectrum of responses from one
hundred percent attendance to as you
identify the lowest in in voucher and
indeedly I'll speak to the police and
crime Commissioner in won't show today
and he was very keen to explain that and
to be held to account to his electorate
personally so I'd leave that to him but
we have to make choices the reality the
harsh reality is policing has taken
twenty six percent out of its cost base
it's been congratulated for that quite
properly by the government and indeed
the prime minister but there's a
consequence and chief constables have to
make very difficult and hard decisions
about where they put the resource and
where they can make the best impact and
sadly on occasions that does mean police
officers won't attend every call
immediately providing of course it's no
immediate risk or harm and in those
cases there's a hundred percent
attendance right yeah so you we've
talked about this before about how you
develop best practice we know that this
is a very patchy picture some forces
we've mentioned the net they've got an
approach it's not necessarily one that's
copied successfully elsewhere how do you
make sure that best practice is minute
across the country what it did report as
I've said the bulk report there are
numerous examples identified by Roger
Baker the HMI of really good practice
across a huge spectrum of police core
activity in the report also identifies
we have a college of policing now I'm
privileged to be on the board of
directors and one of the key roles of a
college is to do precisely that but we
must remember it is unsurprising in a
devolved policing model with 44 forces
if you include